immune system of our body is comparable
to the defense system of country now
defense system of a country has
different divisions like a Air Force
like a land force and a Navy and all
this among all this division what is
important is communication so there
should be several ways by which all
these divisions of the army of a country
can communicate between each other and
they can communicate between radio
walkie talkies satellite phone etc also
our immune system should devise a
communication strategy such that all the
players of the immune system can
communicate with each other immune
system cells communicate with each other
either directly going to each other
physically or they communicate by
several wireless medium in their case
this wireless mode of communication is
via small chemical messengers known as
cytokines so in this video I would talk
about cytokine mode of action six
families of the cytokine signaling
mechanism and the function of the
cytokine families and also the critical
use of cytokine so if you haven't
subscribed my channel why are you
waiting for
please hit that subscribe button and
don't forget to like my video so
communication modes used by a normal
cell could be either in decree where the
cell secrets of a messenger molecule
here depicted in cream which flows
through the bloodstream and reaches its
distant target cell other mode of
communication could be paracrine where
the cell is not so far away the target
cell is not so far away from the cell
signaling the second cell which is
secreting the signal so that is paradigm
another is autocrat means the cell
itself signals a molecule which works
upon the cell itself
now the immune system uses mostly para
Krang an autocrine mode of come
systems now how it works is there could
be inducing stimulus which can allow for
activation of specific cytokine genes
and that would ultimately lead to
cytokine mediated signaling in the
recipient cell or the target cell and
the target cell would have a variety of
biological effect due to this cytokine
it would either divide it can
differentiate or even sometimes it can
get apoptosis and it can undergo
apoptosis orbit it so parity of outcome
could be happy could be awkward off on
cytokine signaling so let's just breathe
through the various functions of
cytokine so cytokines are used useful
for multiple different purposes in the
immune system for example lymphocyte
migration requires a specific type of
cytokine known as chemokines so
lymphocyte cells moves along the
chemokine gradient to reach their
destination also development of several
immune cells for example b-cell require
specific cytokine derived signaling so
interleukin 7 and interleukin 7 receptor
mediated signaling is very important for
feed eg recombination which is important
for a piece of development to occur also
T cell differentiation is also important
process for our immune cell and T cell
differentiation requires several
different cytokines and several
different cytokines guide the
differentiation of T cell to several
platoons of T cells and I have several
videos on P cell development and role of
cytokines in T cell differentiation so
you can watch those videos also several
cytokine can give inflammatory responses
such as il 6 il 1 etc that we would be
discussing very soon
also T cell activation requires several
cytokine signaling
also in several cases cell proliferation
or proliferation of the immune component
cells requires in interleukin horth
which is one type of cytokine so that
means cytokine is widely used by the
immune system for several purposes for
growth and development for
differentiation for reaching the
destination of the voice migration and
also manifestation of inflammation
specific activation and cell
proliferation so a wide variety of
function is performed by the cytokines
now here is the six cytokine families
namely interleukin one family and it's
family member are shown here one of the
important most family member of
interleukin one family is Intel il 1
which is the prevalent pro-inflammatory
cytokine second is hematopoietic a motor
protein family and one of the most
important memories interleukin 2 because
interleukin 2 is very important for T
cell proliferation
now interferon family is very
interesting and interferon family has
interferon alpha beta gamma and
interferon lambda interferon alpha and
beta are important and they are
pro-inflammatory whereas in interferon
gamma gives a protection against viruses
and interleukin 10 or il-10 is an anti
inflammatory molecule secreted by the t
regulatory cells there is a important
family also known as tumor necrosis
factor family so tumor necrosis factor
family has TNF alpha TNF beta cd40
ligand Fastback a pre etc as their
family member interleukin 17 families
recently discovered and prevalent
membres interleukin 17 another family is
chemical family chemical families
members are CCL 19 CCL 3 CCL 2 etcetera
etcetera and we would look at the
function and their more of action
gradually in this video so stay tuned
and watch the whole video so first we
would talk about the interleukin 1
family now interleukin
family members are mostly
pro-inflammatory cytokines so aisle one
alpha L 1 beta aisle 18 aisle 33 all of
these are pro-inflammatory cytokines
means that they give rise to swimming
redness etc etc and all the inflammatory
sites so also Aisle one family has
anti-inflammatory members which are il-1
RA which is il-1 receptor antagonist IL
36 receptor antagonist and all these
things so they are also secret adverse
enough receptor antagonist which
actually oppose the inflammatory
cytokines of il-1 family and thereby
check information so here how the il-1
receptor mediated signaling occurs so il
1 binds to it il-1 receptor il-1
receptor is a heterodimer
consisting il receptor 1 + IL receptor
acp now all of these circular domain
that you see are actually IG fold so
this receptor is of a broad family known
as IG super family and it's the same
family member of an antibody and at the
cytoplasmic end it has an important
domain which is known as the my detail
binding domain or or TIR domain so Miley
88 also have is known as myeloid
differentiation protein and it also has
this di ultimen they interact with each
other and works as a scaffold my d88
works as an adaptor or a scaffold which
would allow Association of track 6 which
is a TNF receptor associated factor and
trap secured activator important kinase
known as Iraq for or Iraq 6 so Iraq's
are basically interleukin receptors
associated kinase Iraq does very
important function so in the cell there
is another important kinase known as
step colonies so that Chi is is
inhibited in a complex where tab 1 and
tab
to which our that associated proteins or
that binding proteins are sequestering
back
so this death kinase is not freed for
further downstream function what Iraq
does is
phosphorylating tap 1 and degradation of
the temp 1 and temp 2 complex and
thereby freeing tack 1 stack is free
it can also phosphorylate I take a beta
of these NF Kappa beta complex once
phosphorylated IG capito becomes
unstable and ubiquitinated so NF Kappa
beta becomes free and NF Kappa beta
moves to the nucleus in there will give
rise to transcription of specific genes
including cycling T which give rise to
sell you division so one once it's this
particular signaling cascade has a
proliferative role also it give rise to
several pro-inflammatory molecules which
ultimately give rise to the inflammatory
signs and symptoms so over all functions
of il-1 so il-1 is a prevalent
pro-inflammatory cytokine so definitely
it would increase vascular bus
permeability it also modulate adaptive
immune response that means immune
response of a b-cell and t-cell
indefinitely force the vascular surface
to express several adhesive molecule
which in turn slows down specific immune
cells such as neutrophils in the
vascular surface that helps in neutral
extra a physician in the injury site
also il-1 forces the liver to form
specific acute phase proteins which are
in turn important for inflammation now
we would come to him at a protein family
now human protein family name come from
the hematopoietic pretty potent stem
cell so he they are all important
earlier they are thought very important
for this hematopoiesis function
now hematopoietic family has important
members one of the most important member
is interleukin 2 and interleukin 2 has a
very important role in the immune system
so the basic characteristics of this
metal working family is there has a four
bundle helix so this is the structure of
the forehead expanding that
hematopoietic will be put in that
hematopoietic family cytokines possess
now let's say this T cell is actually
activated by a a peptide that is
presented on a class 2 MHC by a
macrophage or any other antigen
presenting cell now this would
ultimately give rise to two signals for
differentiation or proliferation of that
particular t-cell and the third signal
is actually interleukin 2 the
interleukin 2 actually works in
autocrine fashion and works on the same
t-cell and that helps the T cell to
undergo cell division and that
ultimately the naive T cell then would
proliferate and form a pool of memory T
cells and a pool of effector T cell now
these il-2 receptors appears in three
conformation in a high affinity
conferring conformation where il-2
receptor has three chains namely alpha
beta and gamma it can also appear in an
intermediate affinity form where it has
Peter and Komachi and also it can only
appear in a singular form of alpha chain
which is a low affinity receptor now
here is a list where these receptors are
found where this intermediate affinity
receptors are found in mostly resting T
cells and natural killer cells and
mostly the high affinity receptors and
the low affinity receptors are found on
the surface of activated cd8 positive T
cells and cd4 positive T cells now the
question is if activated cd8 positive T
cell and the scene EA for positive T
cells
has this high-affinity receptor then
what is the function of the low affinity
receptors it turns out people speculate
that low affinity receptor could be
useful to sequester il-2 on the surface
of these cells and then later pass on
back pass that on to the high affinity
receptor however it's actually mode of
action is not totally clear other family
members include g-csf gm-csf and aisle 3
I am 5 etc so they also have two
different configurations one is a low
affinity receptor configuration another
is a high affinity receptor
configuration why do they have both sort
of receptor is still unclear but
whatever it may be the reason is the
most the overall functionality of the
american family of cytokines are first
of all hematopoietic will be put in stem
cell differentiation and poly freshen
neutrophil proliferation basically
degranulation and be fulfilled
proliferation and also they help me make
a carrier sign at one of site
differentiation now we would talk about
interference as the name suggests
interference means that could interfere
with some processes and I have a
detailed video describing the
interference and their mode of action so
if you haven't watched this video you
can watch the video in my immunological
a list now interferon has three families
interferon plus one interferon plus two
and interferon class three interferon
class one comprised of interferon alpha
and interferon beta whereas class 2 has
interferon gamma and interleukin 10
interferon plus 3 is a newly discovered
family compras
comprising of interferon lambda now
interferon alpha and beta help in T
helper cell differentiation
switching the T help naive T helper
cells fate toward th one positive th one
cd4 positive T cell now interferon alpha
and beta also works like an alarming
signals so macrophages
and dendritic cells secrete interferon
alpha interferon beta which interns
along nearby cells to come to that
particular location now interferon gamma
has a huge role against a viral
protection so it can lead to so what
happens is so when a cell is killed by a
cd8 positive T cells that dead cell
secretes some molecules and these
molecules turned out to be interference
now what happens is in turn the
interference which is secreted from a
viral affected infected cell that bind
to interferon receptor interferon
receptor signaling give rise to specific
gene transcription which ultimately
produce antiviral molecules and that in
turn saves the neighboring cells from
further virus infection so what are
these antiviral molecules produced by
interferon signalling so let's say the
interferon first of the one of the most
important molecules that are synthesized
due to the interferon signalling in the
neighboring cells is protein kinase our
protein kinase are actually binds to
viral dsDNA and inhibits its translation
also putting that as our being a kinase
can phosphorylate initiation factor to
alpha and indirectly inhibit translation
second strategy is forming 2:5 all us
Incas which actually binds with vitality
as RNA and make it degraded by rnase El
activity so the mRNA is getting degraded
and no viral protein is formed in a
third strategy what happens is MX
protein get polymerized and they inhibit
the viral coat assembly such that
several life processes of the virus
could be interfered by the function of
these interference and hence their name
is interferon next
his chemo kind family now chemokines
family works like a chemical messenger
and they formed chemical gradient for
example here is an injury site and the
chemokines are secreted by several of
cells which are in this injury site and
the chemo kind forms a gradient a high
to low gradient from where the infection
happens to a distant part so any
molecule any specific immune cells which
is migrating along the blood vessels
would see the would identify the site of
injury or the site of pathogen
innovation by migrating along through a
low to high chemical gradient so in
other words they help in cell migration
and immune cell navigation sort of thing
so one of the most important thing that
they do is they increase the surface
expression of the adhesive molecules on
both the surface of the specific
neutrophil or basal field inside the
blood vessel and also the capillary
apical endothelial cells of the blood
vessels so that held the particular
immune cell to stop and rose slowly such
that that the rapid Isis or neutrophil
or basal field extravasation could occur
and it can reach the injury site now all
these chemical chemical receptors are
actually g-protein coupled receptors and
they can work in multiple different
signaling pathway they can activate one
of the most important signaling pathways
which regulates growth and cell division
which is mTOR signaling pathway where
protein kinase c they can also activate
grass and raskin give rise to downstream
effect by map kinase signaling pathway
all these things works by AP one family
transcription factors which give rise to
particular through proliferative genes
such as c make cyclin d1
also some genes like pro anti-apoptotic
genes like PC on Excel and
to etc etc also phospholipase C beta
mediated signaling can release NF Kappa
beta to the nucleus and first of all
since these chemokines help in cell
migration so cell migration requires a
lot of cytoskeletal rearrangement and
the cytoskeletal rearrangement and them
fail migration could occur because a
chemical mediated signaling activates a
lot of small GTP is known as ro of cd4 T
to react all these things are known to
activate the actin polymerization and
thus cell migration is regulated by
chemokines signaling now we come to and
all these kind kind of signaling would
ultimately leave to either cell
proliferation cell migration or cell
differentiation now we would come to PMF
family or tumor necrosis family tumor
necrosis family has TNF alpha and TNF
beta all are pro-inflammatory and also
they are actually apoptotic but not only
they are about protic they can sometimes
give rise to survival signal as well for
example so for example TNF alpha and TNF
beta that are secreted from macrophages
are actually cueing resistant
inflammatory signal whereas Baffin April
has certain important role in P cell
development and also fast ligand are
actually expressed by cytotoxic T cells
and NK cells and they have certain roles
in actually killing the target cell so
here is the TNF alpha family receptor
now TNF alpha receptor binds with tumor
necrosis factor so 200 crosses factor
binds to that and also they have a
cytoplasmic domain known as L domain now
Brad is also a doctor molecule having
the tails to me so Delta main and then
too many informant interaction makes a
solid scaffold where other signaling
molecules can
and interact so other things telling
molecules known as brief and traffic to
interacts with the tread and ultimately
it activates a particular molecule known
as fat which is fast associated began
with Delta mean now fat actually
converts pro caspase-8 to caspase-8
which is a active form of caspase-8
now once caspase-8 is inactive form it
can cleave pro caspase-3 to a gas phase
3 now gas mystery is a executors gas
phase gas phase 3 can further to you
downstream a lot of signaling molecules
a lot of proteases which would
ultimately cleave the nucleic acid in
the nucleic acid in the nucleus the
cytoskeletal framework of the same
ultimately it would program the tip of
the cell but there's the other filament
of signaling used - same receptor so
sometimes TNF alpha and TNF alpha
receptor mediated signaling could lead
to survival and that case the signaling
happens in a little bit different way so
definitely trad reap and trap etcetera
interacts with the death domain of the
TNF receptor but the key differences
when CI cellular AFP and CIA p2 and
Lubeck binds to this complex it don't
allow the leap to fall down from the so
it allows the leap to fall down from the
complex and what happens is read freeze
tag kindness from its inhibitors which
are tab 2 and f/11 stack is activated
that phosphorylate several target
proteins in the map kinase signaling
pathways such as our make etc and also
that phosphorylates ikk beta in the NF
Kappa Kappa beta signaling pathway
releasing mnnf kappa peta and such that
in
capito can migrate to the nutrients so
once in earth kappa BTW pathway is
activated one of the most important
dance to molecule is known as a flip now
sleep safely is an inhibitor of broken
approach caspase-8 so you can suppress
caspase-8 and actually check the
apoptotic pathways and also map kinase
pathway and if Kappa beta pathway can
ultimately give rise to a lot of
proliferative gene and anti-apoptotic
chains such as PCL 2 bcl-xl and cell
division related machines like cyclin D
cycling me and simple so all these
things can give rise to proliferation so
it depends whether B is TNF alpha
mediated signaling would either give
rise to F or proliferation depends which
intermediate signaling players they're
using now we come to the clinical use of
these cytokines now in brain which is
actually TNF receptor and IgG chimera is
widely used in treatment of rheumatoid
arthritis then Humira
which is a monoclonal antibody against
TNF receptor is used for treatment of
remoter
critics and cons disease refer on a
which is interferon alpha 2 a is used
for treatment of hepatitis B here is a
leukemia Kaposi sarcoma and hepatitis C
ebonics
which is interferon beta a is used to
treat multiple sclerosis so these days
cytokines
specially interferons are used for
several clinical purposes so that was my
video on cytokines if you liked my video
give it a quick thumbs up don't forget
to like share and subscribe thank you
you